hello today we're gonna be having a look
at the warlord class represented today
by our friend AK Lundy dozen she is an
old veteran she's been through many wars
you see she's lost an eye she's lost
well big chunk out of her cheek there
she just wants to retire she's come out
here to the islands find a nice little
place retirement home and what did she
find he finds absolutely bloody freezing
and it's full of filthy dwarves and
stuff like that messing up her views now
this is in the middle of the game but
this is actually a genuine game been
planning it myself for the last couple
of days testing things out as you can
see I've been doing some remodeling I've
cast a spell it's cold seven minute
tropical Empire this isn't actually a
warlord spell this is from my fire
specialization I've chosen and what's
happening is I'm slowly spreading
tropical terrain out from all of my
cities now orcs as a race look at this
guy well generally they don't mind
tropical fact in this particular city
they love it
well as the races however don't like
tropicals tropical terrain so that means
if somebody would say and dwarf who
dislikes tropical say I come along maybe
at a disadvantage fighting in my land so
there is no reason to do this I could
also lets me make uses another fire
spell called the mane of the Sun which
I've already cast a little of my cities
what this does is it modifies the city
to tell it the city and everyone next to
it loves the tropical area and it cost
it on this city look how happy they are
I'm plastic now just finished a piece of
research let's have a look
warlord is all about battle all about
fighting and not only do they get lots
of powerful fighting units they also get
a lot of abilities that improves the
units that they've already got so this
affect every single Archer cavalrymen
infantrymen pikemen just about every
single fighting unit you've got and
gives them more martial arts that's plus
fines against opportunity attacks and
retaliation the tanks that's huge
and very big event
to gym battle so we're going to have to
select new research for us now see
you've got our spell but what we can
choose now now someone fire elemental
once again from our fire research that
gives us a nice of a powerful big tough
monster authority of the sword that lets
us grow as a domain of one of our cities
and I think we will choose thoroughbred
mounds what this is going to do is give
+15 hip twist every single cavalry man
we've got and we have a lot of galleries
there we go
their province quickly fit by domain of
the Sun made a monster hunter somewhere
festival of magic now all of our cities
are very happy due to the aforementioned
domain of the Sun spell that means
occasionally they'll randomly generate
events like this which is giving us
bonus manor are we going to do first now
as you can see I've pretty much locked
down this whole place and I was just
about to start standing my scouts out
explore the nearby area but nice little
islands as you can see it still green so
I've got interesting over here and this
is one of our heroes it release faith
hand he's actually a theocratic a little
army and let's go in here this is a tomb
usually have magic items and stuff for
us we can use to make our heroes better
and maybe send a bit of extra money to
have a look see what's inside so we're
gonna be fighting against some undead
and he'll out
should be fun let's get to it
okay here we are deep underground about
to fight the evil forces of the undead
here comes up our calm casters archons a
race from the previous game where they
were called the hymen a bunch of angelic
creatures I disappeared after a
mysterious event there only the undead
remnants remain you also have some
hellhounds and a carrion bird here now
we're in a tomb it was a special effect
maskers all of our units are from - to
assistance and - to defense which is
actually fairly big a bad news for us
orcs or say they're tough and strong
naturally have a lower resistance and
other races which means we take extra
damage from non-physical sources such as
the ice bolts that you saw the casters
fire now what have we got in our army we
have got here Monster Hunters now
Monster Hunters are a kind of irregular
so highly mobile ranged close combat
sort of everything unit main thing that
they can do is they have monster slayer
which is +3 damaging as all monsters
like some very good for clearing out
treasure sites like this so they're
going to do extra damage against these
carrion Birds over here also extra
damage yes this hellhound is kind of
hiding over in the corner over there
also have these it's a war breed one of
my favorite warlord units it's a big
beefy tier 3 monstrosity half Hawk half
Olga the consequence of some kind of
horrible ill-fated eugenics program big
spiky Club love it and here we have a
horse Archer that kind of sort of based
on the famous Mongolian warriors who
swept across the steppes my fairy hat
not particularly appropriate for the
entropic 'el area that we've made but
you know it's a fashion statement and
finally these guys bizarre cars
half-naked big axe only need armor on
the shoulders let's go guys basically
they said somewhere between infantry and
cavalry is very fast hit very hard they
charge and they're one of the two
starting warlord units very nice to have
you'll also notice that this guy all of
our other units have +1 spirit damage
I've chosen an ability for earless hero
our theocratic Auld sacred arms
and what that means is every single unit
in the army
gets plus one spirit strength which is
extremely useful when fighting the
undead
now let's get to it so I think biggest
threat is probably this carrion bird
since he does belite damage so sending
the war breed first or trying to absorb
some hits
Dave guarding there's no point in trying
to flank him guarding his compass
ylang-ylang if you can see he hits hard
and he and he can take a few hits as
well so the monster hunter should be
able to come in and finish this guy off
looks like it take him down well now
what else getting a theocrats are very
very good against the undead you'll see
here 40% spirit weakness just with a
charge and just with a charge we can
already take him down to almost no
health but we have a pure spirit ray
attack so the seam is that enough to
kill him 8 to 12 times - now I'll just
charge it in Koran random boy donk he
survived so when that's going to finish
him off the undead are actually quite
tough especially against normal ranged
attacks will blink away at him but I
think he's gonna he'll be surviving into
next turn
ok now these guys are coming round over
here so we'll send the berserkers to try
and pin them down you can see martial
arts here was reducing the amount of
damage that we take from his physical
retaliation but it does not help us
against the fire attacks and orgs having
low resistance Oh weak against fire
attacks they do damage but they get hit
hard back who else have we got
sending the mounted archers as well yeah
not much we can do with them so gums
send them every day and here to help
with the hellhounds
sit see if maybe we too late now isn't
it
oh we don't even have any casting points
cuz I spent at all of the world maps a
gun got some new spells either okay see
what we can do with the independence
have to say okay he looked guys just
healed himself and how like a rather
foolish thing that's my hero exposed
there so the archers are taking
advantage of that what happened over
there yep looks like our berserkers
managed to finish off the hellhounds
and now let's flank these arches and try
and get rid of them they were pain can
kill him
yep nice a couple of nice flanking
attacks and they go straight down and
finally this guy now our hero here is
actually in a bit of trouble didn't 11
hit points left so cut two hits and
he'll go down so once again maybe
bringing back up from the war breed
takes a lot more than some wimpy dead
mage to stop that guy donk that's the
end of them and the tomb is ours okay so
let's see what prizes we've won in there
some money and a unicorn now this is a
mount item which ear Elise here can ride
currently he has a hellhound which gives
him black protection fire protection and
an ability extra damage against pipe
Menace shielded units the unicorn on the
other hand gives him phase phase is a
one to turn a battle abilities that lets
him teleport to another location very
handy for getting into trouble or for
getting out of trouble
nice tactical thing so let's some use
that instead now not only can you find
items and treasure sites we can actually
make our own and in I believe it's this
city over here I actually have an item
Forge set up so I can show you how we
can make an item so here Elise our
little champion over there has been
doing so well we've decided we want to
give him a sword what kind of sword well
any kind of sword really swords can
carry any of the offensive and charmin
so we can give him extra damage on a
different damage channel we can make him
better it's playing animals
draconians hawks anything we like really
better fighting gets evil better
fighting against good better it well
yeah better at fighting in general
that's what we want we can even give him
the ability to knock down walls so let's
he's a bit of a theocratic oh he's a
holy champion so what should we give him
I know
blondie we'll give him a holy club big
stompy holy club to help him on his way
because he's secret into spirit damage
so give him a nice bit of spirit damage
there and the ability to strike down
Wolf's hatred Wars and we'll call the
weapon dwarf smash ah lovely
oh good a custom enough money to take a
while to mail so we'll just forward sad
but in the best traditions of television
I can show you some stuff I've already
made over on earth Colombia over here
he's got DAB Luna a big flaming axe
gives a +4 or fire damage win a few
strikes and Hot Stuff a fire or a shield
so anytime anyone tries to hit her
there's a chance that the person hitting
I will catch fire she's also got some
stuff that we found from other trailer
types riding a unicorn popular in
fashion this summer now where are we up
here in the frozen north way Ashland is
exploring we've come across a dwarven
strongholds here they're gray
independence now normally we would
negotiate with these people we could pay
them to open their borders we can
privately maybe even they would join our
Empire for just money or they could give
us a quest but we're a warlord we're
about war and battle so prepare to be
destroyed little dwarves we're coming to
get you the very powerful army music
landy we have walk Manticore riders
there's a tier 4 warlords unit big scary
huge amounts of damage high defense lots
of hit points definitely something you
want to have on your side also got aux
shock trooper now this isn't actually a
warlord unit this is an orc unit of any
war can build these
again very strong in flicks bleeding
wounds it has tireless so that means it
doesn't spend action points when it
retaliates its only weaknesses it's for
low resistance so it's very vulnerable
to attacks which don't hit it on the
physical channel we will so for whatever
reason got a dwarf prospector I think I
won him as a prize from doing some kind
of mission or something yeah whatever
time for you to kill your kinsmen no
real reason to do manual combat here
none of these tools a particularly
powerful so we're just Auto combat it
splat we win we really wanted to we
could click this button and we could
watch a replay and see what the AI did
for us here but this is now our city IDO
am back now we could absorb it if we
want it keep it as a dwarf City and then
later on we could make dwarf units
strategically that might be a good idea
dwarves are more expensive than units of
other races but they have plus one
resistance and plus one defense making
them generally the best troops in the
game or statistical average but you know
we're here we don't want any stinking
little Dwarfs messing up our summer
holiday so migrate to walks yep
now because of our spell tropical Empire
from next time onwards very slowly
summer
summer loving he's gonna start spreading
out from this city and enough for now
cuz we've got no casting points and it'd
be nice to be able to use some magic in
battle ok new turn that was quick
that was extremely quick Wow
ok well as you can see it's now very
sunny yeah I believe that because every
I've been running the spell for such a
long time that most of my cities are
full of tropical so all of the tropical
generating output from all of my cities
has been dumped into this place at once
I've brought instant desert if occation
so look we're bringing the sunshine at
high speed sorry that was actually
completely unexpected I've forgotten
that the spell worked like that now over
up here in the Northeast we have another
of our little exploratory missions
this is in Maine as in night owl he's an
Arch Druid hero she's got a very
powerful army couple of Manticore riders
and Oakshott trooper and an oak Black
Knight normal or key cavalry and this
guy the last of the warlord units
haven't seen any more a phalanx with
those big spiky Mohican helmet now
phalanx is a type of pikemen which means
they do extra damage against horsemen
and flying units they are basically
designed for killing heroes and flying
tear Falls and we are going to capture
this thing over here ha ha ha they're
scared no mercy
we are engaging the independent forces
in this heart of the tropics the heart
of the tropics is a special structure
once it's in our domain nobody in our
empire will suffer morale penalties for
being in tropical terrain not that we
suffer that any way but we don't want
this to fall into the hands of the enemy
so it's defended by some spiders this
guy and think that's a cell horse and a
fire elemental which I believe if we
wished we could research and we could
have one of those as well now let's
start off see if we can do some magic
lots of effective spells here it may
know being an Arch Druid for example
could cost Hornet swarm the sort of
version of Chain Lightning which uses
blight damage instead of lightning
damage however as you can see not really
very effective against these guys most
of these creatures have some kind of
blight protection so I'm not going to
use that so the caster's fell from
outside firewalls always fun but we
wanted more of a warlord spell so let's
try berserk what berserk will do is make
the enemy unit Mele attack the closest
unit to it regardless of what it will be
so let's try on this horsey 40% chance
of success is it gonna work
well up minun even ever about a fat
chick anyway might have been usually
that spell is more effective against
creatures who aren't guarding so he's a
bit more room well defended against that
now the man deco riders can move the
fastest so we're gonna send this guy all
the way over to the back here to tie up
this fire elemental the fire elemental
is probably the biggest threat flying in
there bashing fire elemental is Tier
three so even not with our martial arts
to protect us against the physical hit
we still took a fair amount of damage
we've also been affected by immolated
immolated means that we suffer three
damage of return our physical strength
we've been reduced as well as our
defense no resistance so bad news there
but it's a Tier four Manticore rider so
probably doesn't really need to worry
what else have we got
the Phalanx can move in against these
hunter spiders they have the ability to
[ __ ] people and strike although that
guy resisted it crippled units can't
move as far each turn mentok already
sighing - finish them off coming in dong
bye-bye
and the Shock Troopers can come in and
take these spiders oh they didn't laugh
very long either and the Black Knights
can charge a charge anywhere out of move
range and ooh as I mentioned earlier we
can teleport because we're riding a
unicorn
however since we're an arch through it
we also have the befriend animal ability
which outdoor turns is this gonna work
on this fellow do we have a new horsey
friend we have a new Rossy friend
fantastic in turn see what they're gonna
try and do not much been a bit of a
blitzkrieg for them so Oh hating my
horse leave my horse alone okay you'll
pay for that
no one touches my little pony and lives
so where do we go from here well we have
many tools to help us we have
battlefield spells such as bloodbath
which grants +5 damage to every unit on
the field relentless army which gives
all of our units work tireless allowing
them to retaliate and to opportunity
attacks for free on the world map we
have spells like deathmatch with doubles
and armies move points whilst at
removing their health
we have conquerors feast which makes the
morale effects of invasions more
pronounced all leading up to the
ultimate spell global assault which
grants every single one of our units
charge first strike and promotes them to
elite rank
you
you